so last month discovery media merged
with uh warner media to create a new
media conglomerate creatively called
warner brothers discovery you'll notice
how all the people in media who are so
concerned about elon musk taking control
of twitter rarely batnai when these
giant corporations merge or buy each
other out or come together through other
means of corporate copulation and form
these giant monopoly behemoths
that is they aren't concerned until they
start losing their jobs as was the case
over at cnn when the newly formed warner
brothers discovery started cutting off
the dead limbs starting first with that
rotting useless piece of lumber called
cnn plus the goal is to you know bring
everything all of the various
smaller streaming services owned by the
company under discovery plus and hbo max
now after the merger and the merciful
euthanizing of cnn streaming service
warner brothers discovery needs some
successes you know it needs some hits
uh needs to get some attention needs it
needs it needs hits is what it needs and
it apparently believes that it has just
that with a new series just announced
debuting on discovery plus in a few
weeks called generation drag
this is a reality show produced by tyra
banks and revolving around
five child cross dressers as they
prepare a bit for a big drag show in
denver which invites quote teen queens
kings and non-binary performers ages
eight to 18.
now the children featured on the
discovery plus show seemed to run that
age gamut from
very young to simply young and all of
them of course too young to be involved
in the liberal west version of bacca
bazi
discovery released a trailer for this
abomination on friday uh the comments if
you go to youtube are disabled i wonder
why um you can actually see why they're
disabled when you watch the clip let's
watch this
welcome to the pink palace my lovely
friend
i first discovered drag at 13
i didn't know what it was but i knew i
wanted it
put on the wig and the makeup and i'm
someone completely different i'm so
pretty my drag name is vanessa shimmer
and she is just a force you can not
reckon with
how do i parent a child that wants to do
drag
i never expected drag to be a part of
our lives oh my god these are so cute
these are problems i never thought i had
to prepare for
what i love about drag is the glitz and
the glam
pause it here for a moment because i
want to answer the question that the
abusive mother asks albeit rhetorically
she asks how do i parent a child who
wants to do drag and her answer on how
to parent the child is to uh not parent
him at all to instead allow him to be
swept along by whatever forces are
influencing him and simply stand by
while he's used and abused in this way
although that's probably a far too
generous interpretation of this woman's
role and motives given that she's not
only allowing her child to do drag but
also putting him on television it's
pretty clear that the forces influencing
the child and driving him to crossdress
are at least partially his parents
as the horror movies tell us it's coming
from inside the house
there are a couple more points to be
made here i think um some of which
require us to unfortunately watch a
little bit more of this which uh
we will do now watch
noah and i'm transgender
have you talked to mom and dad about the
pictures
what do you think of taking these photos
down the constant reminder that i had to
pretend i was a boy
do you think a mom would ever want to
watch me do drag how do i explain this
to my child that she doesn't fully
accept novella
making friends has been a hard thing for
me to do when i'm becoming nemo
become more confident let me make sure
you are appropriately fluffed
this transition has been difficult for
them but
they try and that's all you can ask for
it's important for kids to understand
that they're not alone
so my mom started draguton kids and
their families are coming from all over
the country where we get to be our true
selves oh god
this is happening
this is a place of love and support
because we need that in this world
this is me
and you better like it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now one interesting thing that you see
there when you watch this is that uh it
seems like every child
featured in the show
actually has what appears to be
um a father
in the picture
and you notice one there the father
himself is wearing the drag wig
now that's probably not a coincidence
i'm sure they they selected for that
because they didn't want to
uh you know
they didn't want to promote the
stereotype that boys who get involved in
this kind of thing oftentimes don't have
fathers so they they selected families
where there's a father there in the
picture
but that only emphasizes the fact that
there are many different kinds of
fatherless homes and when we talk about
the fatherless home epidemic oftentimes
that that boils down to the statistics
of fathers who are physically not in the
home but if you're just looking at that
you're not getting the full picture
because the actual epidemic is much
much larger than that
and there are plenty of homes where
there's a where there's a father
physically present like his he's a
living breathing organism taking up
physical space within the home but he's
not present in any other way he's not
spiritually present he's not emotionally
present he's not psychologically present
he's certainly not present as a source
of of discipline and direction which is
one of the one of the primary things
that children need fathers for so these
are all fatherless homes even if they're
um
their fathers
quote unquote are physically there
now the child at the end there says uh
this is me and you better like it
but tragically he's wrong on both counts
because he's been led wrong he's been
led astray this is not him when he's
dressed up in girl clothes and prancing
around on stage for the enjoyment of
predator adults who should all be in
prison
that's not him
what is presented on stage is a
rejection of everything that comprises
his authentic self a rejection of his
masculinity his boyhood his childhood
his innocence
all of that is sacrificed and he's not
choosing to sacrifice it because he
doesn't know what he's giving up or what
the consequences will be the adults in
his life are sacrificing it for him
now the fact that this show exists
and um is produced by one of the largest
media companies in the world and um
one of the most famous
and mainstream models in the world tyra
banks is involved as well
and that they're putting this out there
at a time when they're such intense and
eminently justified backlash over this
kind of thing you know that all proves
yet again of course beyond any shadow of
a doubt that there is a conspiracy to
groom and sexualized children warner
brothers is planting its flag here they
they will promote
the grooming and sexual abuse of
children no matter how much outrage it
provokes
they're even willing to lose money to do
it
you know last week we had the um
the clip from good morning america from
a few years ago when they were talking
about child drag performers and they
brought a child
drag queen quote unquote on stage
and that was done at a time
as evidenced by the fact that hardly
anyone noticed when they did it
that was done at a time when when the
media could do stuff like this and uh
and get away with it
now you do this there's going to be
outrage
and they know that
so they're willing to
deal with that they're losing willing to
lose money to do it that's how important
it is to them
and that's a that's also an important
point to be to be made here and to
realize but there's another point i want
to make as well
consider this um
child
beauty pageants
events where young girls are caked in
makeup and paraded around on stage
those are dying out all across the
western world there's been even a push
in some countries including in this one
to ban the pageants outright but even if
they haven't been successfully outlawed
yet they're certainly and thankfully not
nearly as popular as they once were
there is wide mainstream agreement that
it is inappropriate to get your daughter
involved in something like this
worse than inappropriate it's
exploitative and abusive
this is one of the reasons why the
horrible tlc show toddlers and tiaras
was cancelled back in 2013
and even people who won't necessarily go
that far in describing the pageants
maybe won't call them abusive and
exploitative
even most of those people will admit
that it's it's controversial at any rate
you can go to pretty much any left-wing
media outlet and find articles that have
been written denouncing these kinds of
pageants
certainly if discovery which owns tlc
had announced last week a revival of
toddlers and tiaras
there would be widespread outrage over
the decision and it would be outrage
echoed by the left wing and in the
mainstream media
after all why do you need
to dress
little girls up like fashion models and
kick makeup on their face
and then send them out on stage to strut
around is this how little girls should
be spending their time
the answer of course is no and most
people seem to agree
these days
anyway that the answer is no
and yet
if you take little boys
and put them in dresses
and cake them in the makeup
suddenly many of the people who said
that this sort of thing sexualizes
little girls are okay with it
more than okay they celebrate it in fact
tyra banks herself on her short-lived
talk show 10 years ago
addressed the issue of child beauty
pageants and treated it as a
controversial subject she apparently was
against it
now she's producing a show about drag
pageants for boys
how can this be explained
have these people suddenly decided that
what was sexualization for girls isn't
for boys
no the answer is not that they don't
think that these drag shows sexualize
kids it's that in this case
that's exactly what they want to do
you know sexualizing girls is wrong they
say
but sexualizing boys for the sake of
promoting the lgbt lifestyle
well that's an entirely different matter
as far as they're concerned
and that i think is the real point
behind all of this
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated